[Music]  i was in the woods  there was a man chasing me  but you never left your house  brain these episodes get increasingly  worse each time you try going off your  meds  i want to get better i really i do have  you run through your questions  is this possible  caleb is anyone else reacting to it  looking forward to having back in class  right  careful she might go all carry on us  everyone thinks i'm a freak when am i  gonna get to meet this caleb  i like spending time with him you okay  it could be a trigger oh  did you hear that what girl next door is  she was screaming for help  my neighbor she kidnapped a little girl  and she's keeping her inner attic we  have to go inside  are you okay we need to take her to the  hospital she wants you to think i'm  crazy so that she can send me away  do you think it's possible that you  might be projecting your own fears  what if that was me up there no it's not  you  she's not real  [Music]  you